An alternative approach to trying to create
better solutions for sequential consistency, which programmers
naturally might expect, is to actually relax
the consistency. That is, we tell the programmers
that they cannot really expect sequential consistency.
But we can still tell them that
they can expect something. And this relaxed
consistency models that are not really sequential consistency,
but they're not just like anything goes, usually
differ in terms of what types of orderings
due they enforce. There are really four types
of ordering. There is ordering between writes to different
locations. There are orderings between writes to some
locations and reads of other locations. There is ordering
between reads and subsequent writes in program order,
and between reads and other reads in program order.
Sequential consistency says that basically program execution
must obey all four types of ordering at
all times. If we actually reorder something, we
have to fix any situation where that would
result in a different outcome than program ordered
execution. So we're allowed to reorder things, but
we have to always hide that from anybody
being able to see it. In relaxed consistency
models some of these types of ordering need
not be obeyed at all times. Usually the
first type of ordering that will not be
obeyed is the read-read. So if we maintain
the ordering between writes and between writes and
reads, but just allow reads to proceed out
of order, then we say that we have
a less relaxed model than if we allow reordering
of other types. So if we told the
programmers that you have to write programs without assuming
that reads are done in correct order, then the
real question is, but how do we then write
correct programs to begin with? So for example, how
do we do flag synchronization if we cannot expect
that after waiting on a flag, we will be able to read the new value of the data?